fabien roussel députés du parti
communiste du nord
bonsoir fabien roussel merci à toi un
mot sur rt france pourquoi avoir saisi
le conseil constitutionnel
d'abord parce que avec plusieurs de mes
collègues de différents groupes de
gauche nous pensons que ce texte de loi
contrevient des principes de notre
constitution notamment sur les libertés
pas seulement les libertés individuelles
liées à la possibilité de nous déplacer
avec cette possibilité donc de passer en
quarantaine des personnes nous pensons
personnellement je pense que c'est bien
de pouvoir placer en quarantaine des
personnes qui sont infectées de pouvoir
leur proposer d'être mis dans des hôtels
quand c'est quand c'est possible
ce qui nous gêne c'est que la manière
dont ces rédigé dans le texte de loi
ce n'est pas du tout précise et ce n'est
pas assez clair les précisions seront
apportées plus tard par décret et nous
ne les connaissons pas et s'ils avaient
été sauvées sur la base du volontariat
cette mise en quarantaine
bages et c'est sur la base du
volontariat mais c'est un placement qui
peut être fait par donc les équipes
mobiles qui seront mobilisés mais ce qui
n'est pas précisé c'est comment ça se
passera pour la famille pour comment ça
se passera pour les mineurs nous avons
demandé de nombreuses garanties sur ces
questions là sans les avoir
et puis il ya aussi cette question du
fichier qui nous préoccupe je dirais
encore plus parce que autant là qu'ils
ont de la constitution d'un fichier
national pour suivre la chaîne de
contamination est importante et et nous
la soutenons ce principe là ça peut
l'aider effectivement à lutter contre la
pandémie et la circulation du virus
mais ce sont là aussi les modalités de
ce fichier qui nous inquiète parce que
tout le monde pourra en faire partie et
et beaucoup d'informations seront
figureront dans ce fichier
c'est à dire la nature du contact que
nous aurons eu avec la personne affectée
le lieu la tuerie du contact les
circonstances de contact enfin c'est une
vraie fiche de renseignements sur chacun
de nos concitoyens
au prétexte d'avoir été plus ou moins en
contact avec une personne affectée par
ce fut cette fiche par personne devra
être détruite dans trois mois vous y
croyez vous pensez que c'est d'engins
tout de même écoutez c'est pas clair
c'est un principe qui a été mis dans le
texte mais sans garantie aucune
nous avons nous demandé à ce que ce soit
bien écrire noir sur blanc la
suppression de ce fichier
nous avons aussi préféré nous allons
demander
l'anonymisation des personnes c'est à
dire que l'anonymat de chaque personne
contact soit préservé c'est possible en
mettant des codes chiffrés pour pour
chaque personne parce qu' énormément de
monde va manipuler ce fichier des
personnels de santé mais pas seulement
ceux de la sécurité sociale c'est ce des
descentes sociaux des communes
ça c'est des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui auront un accès à ce
fichier national
comment faire alors selon vous fabien
roussel puisque est-ce qu'il faut
identifier et recenser les personnes
malades pour remonter les cas contacts
tout à nous aurions bien aimé nous avoir
un peu plus de temps pour travailler sur
les règles plus strictes qu'il aurait
fallu mettre en place pour avoir un tel
fichier qui effectivement donc le lady
peut nous aider à bien connaître la
manière dont circule le virus et pouvoir
stopper la circulation de ce virus
donc nous ne sommes pas contre la
constitution de deux tel fichier mais
c'est la manière dont il est mise en
oeuvre c'est le fait qu'il ne soit pas
qu'il ne préserve pas l'anonymat des
personnes
et puis le fait est qu'il ya énormément
de monde qui va y avoir accès et que
beaucoup de renseignements y figureront
sur chaque personne chaque citoyen
français peut faire partie de ce fichier
est donc nous aurions aimé nous y mettre
beaucoup plus de garanties nous avons
fait des propositions en ce sens pendant
le débat qui ont tous toutes été
rejetées et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous faisons un recours car
cela contrevient des principes de notre
constitution
alors vous parler du problème de
l'anonymat il ya également le problème
du secret médical puisque les pers
malades vont être recensés par le
médecin c'est lui qui doit inscrire dans
ce fameux fichier le nom du malade ça
pose savuth ce problème de secret
médical sinon bah oui parce que ça a été
un point qui a fait l'objet d'un débat
puisque le secret médical aujourd'hui il
est préservé par les médecins et là
demain
comme ce sera un fichier spécifique
qu'ovide bien sûr tous ceux qui ont
accès à ce fichier sauront que les
personnes dedans sont potentiellement
infectées par le coronavirus vous
imaginez les implications que cela peut
avoir un fichier ainsi recul je pense à
la personne qui voudrait contracter un
prêt auprès de sa banque
et alors si le banquier par avion par un
autre accès à la connaissance et au fait
que la personne est potentiellement
infectées par le virus il n'aura jamais
accès à son prêt bancaire c'est un
exemple que je donne mais c'est ce sont
des choses qui peuvent se vérifier en
somme quand même nous avons surtout dit
qu'un tel fichier ne peut venir que en
plus après avoir avoir mis en oeuvre
tous les moyens pour lutter contre
l'épidémie c'est à dire des masques pour
tous et en accès libre gratuit et la
massification des tests c'est surtout ça
qui est important
on ne voudrait pas que ce fichier ces
brigades mobiles pour aller chercher les
personnes contacts soit un prétexte pour
parce qu'il ya une pénurie de masques
parce qu'il n'y a pas de tests
accessible pour tous
c'est pour ça que c'est d'abord la
priorité pour nous c'est d'avoir des
masques en nombre et accessible pour
tous gratuitement pour chacun de nos
concitoyens et ensuite que l'on puisse
faire des tests partout y compris dans
les entreprises quand des camps des
entreprises le propose que ça puisse
être très or aujourd'hui c'est interdit
oui c'est interdit je vous le confirme
merci beaucoup fabien roussel je
rappelle que vous êtes député du parti
communiste du nord merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur les français